hey be sure to subscribe and hit that
bell for when i do a full review of this
game and all of the other evil dead
games and possibly show off some more
footage i shot with bruce in that video
but for now check this out hey there
everyone it's xavier i'm playing evil
dead with bruce campbell i don't know
what to say it's the coolest thing
that's ever happened to me let's get
into it
you know what gentlemen
actually i hope you do
hi
how are you guys hello very nice to meet
you good luck and um to hell with you
you guys
plus i mean it smells like yeah
you can find me on twitch youtube and
other social media at andy campbell gg
i'm here doing a very special preview of
evil dead the game with some very
special guests including uh my father mr
bruce campbell himself beautiful
i'll be playing as the candarian demon
with the help of the old man and with us
as the survivors we have riley from
slash and cast david cage aka uncaged
games matt sohenke and xavier mendoza
let's get into it oh yeah
good luck everybody you'll need it
that's what i've been hearing i've been
here and it's been uh from what i
understand the best way to play the game
is separately
go out in the woods by yourself try and
win it alone
that always works the best in this game
my play style anyway usually remember
ditch your weapons the candarian demon
won't come after you there's no sport in
it
true true true
all right i'm uh playing as uh evil dead
two hunter ash
uh i just want to be in the support role
i think i could help everyone out that
way yep uh xavier i think you probably
got about the only chance of winning
this
we'll see uh it's just a
it's a hunch i don't know
and i'll be rocking a sweet baby
henrietta this time that's right oh
awesome
the classic
she will shove your face in between her
pendulous boobs
oh
not a guy who's gonna give you a ju
she's gonna give you the jublies there's
nothing you can do about it
you'll die with a smile on your face
i don't know everyone come to meet at
the knock
and there's really nothing wrong with
revealing your your position
it's just it's weakness to hide nearby
exactly you guys see me you see my
marker that's where we're heading uh
yes grab that all right i got a melee i
got arranged i'm ready to rock let's go
okay all right ah let's see let's see
collecting up matchsticks
gotta try and stay in the light yes
those are important i'm turning on my
flashlight oh i need to get to the end
of the flight on the tunnel
all right guys
let's rock and roll
now make sure you all have a melee
weapon and a ranged weapon this is the
time to find them you guys don't need
weapons hey andy they're heading for a
creepy place in the woods that should
help that should help you out
all right everyone let's hold hands
remember the buddy system yeah
bruce said we should separate though and
i don't know about this sticking
together it's the safest way it's the
only way to survive
i don't think he would lie to us
for himself no i want you to trust me i
know what i'm talking about now if we're
going by the movie rules i'll be okay
because chosen one
oh y'all brave going into a tunnel hey
chainsaw ashy boy
that's all you
oh
if there's a chainsaw noise and it's not
me then we should be concerned
it's pretty just another brick right
over here follow the sound of my voice
hey all right here we go
around hey
yo anybody have a weapon that looks like
something you should be concerned about
now just so you know there's not there's
not much blood in this game so
it's it's
this game's a little dry
i might never take that ass
what's going on getting really lucky hey
you go to dark places over here things
say okay all right oh there it is yeah
that's the good stuff that's the beauty
of this game it makes you feel real
lucky by the way everyone group up i'm
gonna give us all shields
as well
oh that got thrown up
nice
all right we're good we're good i'm
going to mark
let's head to the next one
beautiful
oh
you're not a friend oh wait i want to
see this execution though
oh an ambulance perfect
i can give us more shields if we want to
group up
yeah let's do it let's do it
okay
all right let's go
all right we still get stuff from
i'm about to get the zest guys so just
be ready to snag me got some fear levels
got some bad fear levels
i'm trying i'm trying to get it started
yo my body's still tense after that
don't scare me with you i got me in
possession yeah messy real messy
do i need to fight the tree i'll fight
the tree no don't do not fight the tree
i'll hit every branch on the way down we
support trees in this community all
right
um i could use another fire your team
now holds another oh my god i'm out of
my head
all right there you are
green markers where we need to go to
next as well now let's say for the sake
of argument one of us is severely
colorblind
um
uh the blood is very red the blood is
very red
okay i get that we're good
hey take a seat
that's the messy stuff that's a mess
that that's a big old mess man
there we go
we're looking like a real team out here
this is beautiful okay
next time we should get matching
t-shirts i'm moving toward the two
i'm good to go on abilities if anyone
gets possessed stay near me
i got fifty percent of my oh
yeah let's uh let's start let's start
rocking and rolling here
hold on listen i'm a little tubby if you
just my stamina ain't working here
you gentlemen are moving quite quickly
catch up catch up okay i'm not leaving
you behind come on let's go andy is
touching me um let's just
stick by me we got this stick by me
no no no no come on let's go we got this
we're so close my fear is bad
come on come on we got this you're so
close we would just use that power man
don't forget all right all right
who's possessed what huh i i probably
will be possessed soon okay i got you i
got you
oh my fear is getting up there guys
let's start a fire
how do you do that i'm still
my big dumb caveman brain has not
figured out the power of fire yet so any
white icon on the map that looks like a
fire is a fire you could light as long
as you have a matchstick you can light
it oh i'm gonna go well i'm gonna go
light one right now actually because i'm
really like i will cover you someone's
right behind you
cool lightning right now there we go
here we go
warm your chainsaw hands by the fire
why are you possessed that where are you
at where are you at it looks like he's
running me away from the objective
they got a lucky match andy you're gonna
close this out
he's running me to the dark ones which
is probably the most selfish thing i've
ever seen i'm henry look at me
can i reach out to you
you gotta fight it you can beat him this
isn't you that's selfish bastard
i'm coming back oh wow
let's run away from there
okay
if i use dark ones until we have them
dagger we'll get there when we get there
okay um
can you even fight that
later on we can
run that's right i don't want to deal
with that
oh i've been possessed someone want to
knock some sense into me use your amulet
ash use it
come on eddie
do some damage oh god oh god oh god wait
suck on that turn around and smack me
one hit me come here help me out here
there you go yeah all right
oh jeez
light the fire okay
there we go there we go
whoa
doing a little bit of a objective-based
gaming just letting you know
you're so far my objective is to not die
i'm objectively pissed
uh there we go
that's the good stuff
this thing started
i i could use a fire please got one i
would be nice the candarian dagger is
nearly yours
oh it's henrietta use your power use
your health power
no thank you
hey
this torch right here by me
between ash and the game and bruce in
the call i'm hearing him in stereo
you want to head into this house and see
what we got yeah
i got a supply crate here
uh there is a handgun right here if
anyone needs any ranged weapons yeah
check your ammo levels
i've been very i've been considering
ammo
dropping cola there you go
don't let me get away you're not running
sorry sis
there we go red thing okay rely on the
red thing right here
okay you got it you got it you got it
okay i'm doing it i'm doing it
ow
all right
can't get him can't get a word in oh
henrietta's here
guys i'm going to swallow your souls
okay all right not do that give me ass
motorboat top of the catheter i'm
getting the bear hug from hell
[Music]
come on come on come on there we go
healing
it's a blood bath
where you uh
this is this is the moment it falls
apart
you guys walked off without me i was
still getting stuff and i was in the
middle of a fight
getting my steps in
oh boy
hey man he wants to play that way let's
just go and take a car and let's make
him possess that too yes
but we should probably just take a car
just all right do we have a car i think
i think we can run it i think we can run
it
everyone fall in on me so we can get our
get our feet around back away from the
objective there we go we got to keep it
moving okay right here we got this we
got this
are we getting in the car come on cheryl
you got this we're almost there i'm
healing us
oh [ __ ] here we go
i don't want to drive someone else drive
i can drive if you don't want to
well i'm picking go go go just go again
who's driving
someone not me get in there
run run run
[Laughter]
is there anyone who can revive me or is
that a thing or
all right don't worry guys i'll hold
down the fork
okay
i believe in you wow
all right well uh looks like you got
this so
good luck and uh we're all rooting for
you
how ironic that's it i'm uninstalling it
had it all together yeah we were playing
musical chairs in the car
i didn't want to drive because i didn't
know how to drive so i was hoping that
he could take it over and i panicked
find me like a man don't you run in that
storm find me like a man it's 1v1
don't do it run it do it do it
oops i did it
you find evil and you nuzzle your face
and it's evil i can't do it
i should have upgraded my stamina well
done well done hey gentlemen i know we
played really well oh
hey gentlemen i know we played really
well
but that wasn't
you know
i've never been so happy to lose my
friends
who's got the most kills
um riley over there 58. henry i mean
wow
wow
who sucks the most
thankfully not me
because i think we're all winners here
let's have a look
that's what the dead eggs want they want
to separate us okay
you guys are very positive people
because i could not be more disappointed
[Laughter]
as you should be yeah i know good job
that was amazing
special thanks to steve harris joe cal
ryan adam tim willits and everyone else
at sabre interactive who helped me with
this incredible opportunity if i forget
your names i'm sorry i met like 20
people that day
playing games with bruce and andy was an
absolute blast and i have even more evil
dead content coming soon
i'll also link the channels of all the
guys i played with so you can see their
footage too become a patron for some
special behind the scenes video from my
trip out to la and early videos and
other special content see you next time
[Music]
so
[Music]
you